Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
If we wish to populate a virtual world with
photorealistic materials, the last few years
have offered a number of amazing techniques
to do so.
We can obtain such a material from a flash
and no-flash photograph pair of the target
material, and having a neural network create
a digital version of it, or remarkably, even
just one photograph is enough to perform this.
This footage that you see here shows these
materials after they have been rendered by
a light simulation program.
If we don't have physical access to these
materials, we can also use a recent learning
algorithm to learn our preferences and recommend
new materials that we would enjoy.
However, whenever I publish such a video,
I always get comments asking: "but what about
the more advanced materials?", and my answer
is, you are right!
Have a look at this piece of work which is
about acquiring printed holographic materials.
This means that we have physical access to
this holographic pattern, put a camera close
by, and measure data in a way that can be
imported into a light simulation program to
make a digital copy of it.
This idea is much less far-fetched than it
sounds, because we find such materials in
many everyday objects, like bank notes, gift
bags, clothing, or of course or security holograms.
However, it is also quite difficult.
Look here!
As you see, these holographic patterns are
quite diverse, and a well-crafted algorithm
would have to be able to capture this rotation
effect, circular diffractive areas, firework
effects and even this iridescent glitter.
That is quite a challenge!
This paper proposes two novel techniques to
approach this problem.
The first one assumes that there is some sort
of repetition in the visual structure of the
hologram and takes that into consideration.
As a result, it can give us high-quality results
by only taking 1 to 5 photographs of the target
material.
The second method is more exhaustive and needs
more specialized hardware, but, in return,
can deal with arbitrary structures, and requires
at least 4 photographs at all times.
These are both quite remarkable - just think
about the fact that these materials look different
from every viewing angle, and they also change
over the surface of the object.
And for the first technique, we don't need
sophisticated instruments, only a consumer
DSLR camera is required.
The reconstructed digital materials can be
used in real time, and what's more, we can
also exert artistic control over the outputs
by modifying the periodicities of the material.
How cool is that!
And, if you are about to subscribe to the
series or you are already subscribed, make
sure to click the bell icon, or otherwise,
you may miss future episodes.
That would be a bummer, because I have a lot
more amazing papers to show you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!